a new amendment
if you picked up the old one
uh that one's going to be eliminated and
no
madam chair what's the number of the new
yes it's uh
one one one
one
right
no it's this one it's this one
uh
oh
i'd uh hi how you doing
i'd like to call the meeting to order
if i could um
today we are going to be um
this hearing is on the uh
non-germane amendment
uh
amendment
1118 is what was
available
as of last wednesday
thursday
and
we have adjusted the amendment
so that the amendment we will be
discussing today
is
2022-1162
okay and if you don't have a copy of it
mr landrigan has plenty of copies out
there
so
um
since
my name is on the amendment i guess i
will
turn the mic over to
representative weiler and will
present the
amendment
we'll recognize representative umberger
to present the non-germain amendment
to house bill 1661
and members of the house finance
hb one one one six six one which this is
an amendment to
uh was dealing with
career technical
uh center education agreements
the amendment was well i'll just say
that
we had a
work session in division two this
morning on
hb one six six one
and although we did not have a vote on
it
there was no one that
uh objected to what that particular bill
was uh
providing
so
what this amendment does the first
the
the first thing is um
the motor vehicle registration fee
rebate
and what this is is that for every
registered vehicle in the state that
registered from
[Music]
1 july 2021
through
30 june
will receive a 25 rebate
so that's
that's pretty simple
obviously the mechanics of that will
need to be
worked out with
with safety
but
and i know that mr lavoy is here and
will be
more than happy to discuss
what he projects
is how we will do it
but you can see on line 14
it just says that the rebate check
will be sent to the permanent mailing
address on file with the department
so
hopefully
people
that may have moved
address corrected with
safety
the second
paragraph seven is that um
we the appropriation is that we
anticipate
uh there's currently 1.6
million
registered vehicles of one type or
another
and so it's estimated that this will be
some
place
around
40 million dollars
to provide
this amount of money the 25 dollars
registrant
number eight
is the um
[Music]
for those of you that may park down on
store street
you know that
that garage is in terrible condition
and we are spending
a lot of money every year
to just to
make it semi-safe
and it is not in a condition at this
point
where it where it
make makes any sense whatsoever
to uh repair
that parking garage
so the proposal that is here is to build
the
parking garage right out there
and
it's currently
houses the
justice department
and we are appropriating the sum of 35
million dollars
towards this now
not all of this 35 million is going to
just build the parking garage we have to
raise
raz race
the building
that is currently there
we have to
move the people that are in there to
another location
and
we also have to
get rid of stores
now tear that down
so that's what the
that's what the 35 million is all about
and i know it says the appropriation
shall not lapse
and i agree with that
but i do think that we need to add a
sentence there that says
any money not expended on this project
will
lapse to the general fund or whatever
whatever those
right words are mickey so
and i know that that you can
take care of that without a without any
problem
so are there any questions that anyone
has on this
any questions from the committee members
representative turcotte for a question
thank you mr chair thanks for the
testimony
a couple questions on uh start with the
item six and line nine
uh could you just explain what is the
purpose behind
instituting this rebate first of all
as you know
we started out with the concept of a
and we found out that
[Music]
it was going to require 92 additional
people
to
monitor or manage the gas tax rebate
and
somebody would get maybe
ten dollars if if you were driving a
regular passenger car
and so we felt that with all of the
administrative costs
and the
amount of gas tax rebate that that
probably was not
the most efficient use of
of the money
and we also looked at
and
we found out well we found out i knew it
but i forgot that we have an obligation
for
seven hundred thousand dollars a month
for a bond
so
that didn't make
that didn't make a lot of sense either
and so as we worked with
safety
this was one of the areas that
we felt we could manage
without a lot of
extra cost
and provide our residents with
um
you know
you can call gas tax relief
in in a different form
and so we believe that this was the best
relief
to and and we also knew
that by doing this that the only people
that would receive the rebate would be
new hampshire residents
so that was why we chose to go
follow up thank you mr chairman thank
you for the answer and the next question
would be
i notice it's a fixed 25 cost
or 25
for each vehicle registered uh the first
question would a
a business that has a 18-wheel truck be
eligible and then the second question
was there any thought given to
making it a percentage
of the
vehicle registration so that somebody
who pays a thousand dollars to regis
register versus somebody who pays a
hundred dollars every time you add
something like that
it costs money
extra extra money
your first question was will the um
owner of a a registered semi received
the 25 the answer to that is yes
but the minute that you start adding
complexities
into
how you are going to
provide the you know provide the rebate
it just simply adds more administrative
cost
any further questions from the committee
members
representative just a question for the
chair will will there be somebody
testifying i hope regarding the
uh raising of the garage yes okay thank
you yes there there will be they'll
they're people here well we have a stack
of cards but um yes we have people that
will speak to both
uh number six and
seeing no further questions thank you
madam chair
thank you mr chair members of the
committee i'm just going to address
eight i'm not going to address the rest
it came to
our attention in the office
that the
store street parking garage
was
at maximum had a lifespan of five years
so this
put the issue of
a new parking garage
pretty high on our menu
that we had to put on the fast track
and as i
heard representative ember talking i
mean we had to find a place to move the
attorney general
we had to obviously find a new building
so there was a lot of pieces of the
some have suggested maybe we wait until
we can't wait another year to put this
on hold
to see if it's going to happen
we need to move forward now we've got an
opportunity
to move the ag
and we've got a building that will work
they've looked at it i haven't had a
chance to get over there yet but they
have been done a tour of it in this new
facility will work
so
i
talked to karen
about
putting
this in the amendment
because
i do not believe we can we can wait
another year
i don't want us to be in the position
three years down the road
of not having a place
for our members to park
we're looking at a
space parking garage
that will cover
all
of the i mean we're still going to have
the yellow b you know the upper and
lower and probably some street parking
but this will get you know a good
portion of our people off the street
you know the architects
have looked at it
and
the the obviously the money we're
estimating that the 35 million will
cover the destruction
of both
store street and the
building now and building a new garage
um
do i want to spend 35 million dollars on
a parking garage no
do we have to
yes
it's it it is getting it is getting
critical
you didn't want to ask me any questions
anyways did you can
afternoon representative
um
the best estimate we've gotten so far is
that's that's where that's for moving
you know moving the ag out the
destruction of the garage
the planning purposes and all that
it's it's
i mean that's the estimate we have right
now is two and a half to three years
so that's putting that's putting right
now store street at just about its end
at ends of its life cycle at that point
and that's why i i i'm
i'm
i don't believe that
it's prudent to wait another year to see
if we want to put this in the capital
budget and move forward uh you know in
i
i thought about that representative
i'm not sure if we could delineate it
maybe we could
you know um
again it's it's uh it's it's going to be
you know our decision the legislature's
decision
whether we want to use the money we have
available to us now or we want to
i mean i'm just throwing figures i'll
take 15 million you know right now and
then bond the other 20 million
i i guess that
you know would probably be an option but
i'm figuring if we've got the money to
pay for it let's pay for the thing and
questions
some of it might i mean it it's it's
it's something that obviously we have to
sit down and figure out all the details
right now representative
and um
unfortunately we're at the uh position
of
our
session right now
you know all the pieces aren't in place
right now but
it's something that um
i didn't feel we could i guess i didn't
yes we have
mr path has been in conversations with
the mayor
and uh we've uh we've we've got the go
ahead
you know the from the from the mayor and
uh the uh town town manager
so
they
they want store street back as much as
we want to get rid of it so
thank conversations
is there any risk
that
i can honestly answer that question
um
i'm sure you have people on this
committee that
are well more better versed than that
thank you mr chairman for the record my
name is terry poff i'm the chief
operating officer of the general court
i've got a little
and i'm here to uh
support the
uh amendment non-germain amendment uh
the funding is the policy decision the
general court will have to make
but the goal of the general court's
always been to work in conjunction with
the department of uh administrative
services and the city of concord
to accomplish a new parking garage
somewhere
store street
is well documented about
becoming into life the
study committee's first study committee
you have fixed it
thank you sir thank you
so we're online now
so in 1988 was the first study committee
and they had a legislative parking
facilities
committee established by the general
court
there was the doj lot purchased
and that was purchased for 2.25 million
i believe from new hampshire savings
bank
and and that was um when we established
also during that discussion in
facilities it was made mention that it
was going to eventually work with the
city of concord on some sort of parking
facility to
migrate from store street now for those
of you who don't know store street was
built and we obtained a lease from the
city of concord for the air rights to
establish that
parking facility it was a lightly built
parking facility out of steel i-beams
and decking
and was established to be actually moved
and taken apart and moved at one point
and we've had a lifespan of
approximately 20 years or so it's well
exceeded that because it was built in
1990 1974
our air lease we still have about 51
years left on the air lease with concord
it was established for a dollar got a
good deal on the air lease
but but currently
going to 93 we did talk about at that
point establishing a cooperative
effort with the city of congress
to
establish a parking facility
everybody knew in 88 it was a problem
had another design
and committee looking for parking
facilities in 2004 again
and
the acting chairman right now was on
that committee actually
so it's this issue has been well
established that the facility is failing
it's gotten to a point now where the
bolts are really on the foundations
aren't even secure they're rusted off
quite frankly
and the stabilization project was just
that just a stabilization project it
wasn't a rehabilitation of that garage
it didn't even really take into account
much of the decking just prior to this
rehabilitation we actually had to
condemn four
to six spaces on there because there was
um
debris falling from below them every
time a car parked on it
so i think the establishment of the fact
that store street is uh is really
rapidly approaching the life has been
there
there's been several
concepts done and we worked with das to
get us some
rfp established in 2019 we had a meeting
developed to re-engage
an actual sighting an actual project a
development team put together to try to
get the project off the ground and get a
refocus on the parking garage itself we
pulled together the city of concord the
governor's office
department of administrative services
um
in the department of justice together in
room 210 211 in 2019 had a meeting there
and then we spun off from that to really
get it going even further to get to a
point where we put out rfps and we had
responses from engineering firms to
establish a design at that point
now at that point there was a design
that was going to uh and the concept was
to include a portion of the garage site
on doj to include some office space
at that point we were thinking
at the time and asking the engineers to
develop a plan to include a space for
doj
for some of doj a space for uh
legislative offices and oversized rooms
at that point we were considering um and
that and then the pandemic hit
so that got kind of scuttled because
there were other areas that were in play
at the time around that state house
capital complex area
and that pandemic put all that on hold
and actually took some of those things
off the table
it's two years have passed since that
point
the deterioration of store street has
become to a critical need as it has been
for decades really but it's really to a
point now that it's it's in a failure
state almost
so that stimulated
the re energizing of this concept and
project to build a parking garage there
the goal has always been to put
something on that site but one of the
gates to doing that has been the doj
resides there so we had to find a
conduit for them to go somewhere so
working
with some local developers and looking
at different spots the problem is
there's 58 000 approximately square feet
needed for a doj to relocate
that's what they're
i believe currently enjoying and that's
what they would want to have
in their new site
there's not too many places that have
that kind of footprint around the city
of concord right now in one spot and so
what we looked at was
what was satisfied by the
supreme court and the
administrative office of the courts was
a facility over at one granite place
that they had
rehabilitated and entered into a 10-year
lease with an option to buy so that said
what's happening over there it ends up
there there may be some opportunities in
the south building of the same complex
so that's where we went to look and so
we brought folks together from the
attorney general's office from the uh
department of administrative services
and did a review of that space it looks
like it may be a pathway to have those
folks have a place to go
that being said there's nothing tangible
about that yet it's still a negotiated
and even an exploratory point at this
point and i'm sure the commissioner of
the department of administrative
services will echo that it's really
conceptual right now we're looking at it
and looking at reaching out to the
developer and seeing what can be done in
that in that phase
and the attorney general's office has
also visited there as i said so they're
looking at you know what are the
requirements how would it be up fitted
to
and what will the cost be associated for
that
so then it comes to the actual
construction of the garage the garage is
uh
we've had conceptual drawings done and
on what that's going to look like it
really is a capacity of approximately
600 or more spaces is what's going to be
required on that footprint
the footprint and the
ground underneath it has had geo um
surveys done to it and to see what the
grounds were like we have all those
documents it's not the best of sites
it's not the worst of sites it's a wet
site everything here is a wet site you
go down nine and a half feet on a
drought year and you get water here so
going below grade isn't really an option
you can always de-water a site it gets
to be expensive when you do things like
that so there are challenges to the site
nothing that i don't think that the
engineers will be not be able to
overcome
the cost of course is up to uh in this
bill indicates up to 35 million dollars
so you look at a pre-pandemic cost with
from valley benzinger we had estimates
of
30 to 32 000 per uh per space
and that was uh for a
facility that would reflect
the dignity and the nature of this
historic district so you could build a
straight out parking garage for much
more economical i think but when you
look at how it has to fit the
neighborhood and what folks
would be expecting from their capital uh
historic capital district i think you
have some other things to consider
so the post pandemic estimate was forty
thousand dollars a square foot from la
valley that was pre-war
so the pre-war uh escalation and uh
costs we don't even know about except
for the it's reflected in the some of
the gas costs and some of the escalating
costs for transportation
so generally a parking garage is made
with pre-stressed concrete these days so
it's basically like a lincoln log set
there's two companies in new england who
currently
do those pre-stressed concretes and
there's approximately a two-year lead
time to get into the queue for those
so that's with depending on design
um and the other companies are out west
and transportation costs bringing those
big pieces would be kind of ridiculous
to engage those
hopefully it won't have to happen once
this gets to fruition
you asked about a timeline i we had
talked with the folks and our partners
over in public works and said how quick
can we do if we do a design for this and
get engineers engaged he said
approximately nine months nine or so to
get uh because it's a parking garage
it's nothing really um
dramatic but you do have to include ev
sites you have to include now uh the
modern garages are designed with
autonomous car sites which are
interesting because you can get more
cars in there because you don't have to
get out of them when they're driving
themselves so it's the things you learn
are very interesting our clientele here
in the general court as you know has an
average age that's a little older than
in some places
and so you have to bring that into
consideration too when you're looking at
proximity and what you'd whether you
have covered access over to the
legislative uh complex
anything on our state house complex so
would that either mean a sky bridge just
a covered area a tunnel perhaps
so those things are included into the
design requests that would be put out as
well to say what are the options for
there
we've had many discussions with the city
of concord uh over the potential uh and
possibility of perhaps closing half of
capitals
to look at that to see whether there'd
be a
a working park a area that you could
make something over or not they've
they've offered and considered that to
consider that and that's what we've
discussed at one point nothing's uh
written in any kind of engineering plan
for that yet but it could be a part of
the overall complex when you look at it
so is this need been established i think
it's very well established and it's
almost bordering on continuing with
store street becoming a liability
for those who don't know and don't
happen to park over there there's now
double layers of netting there to
protect the people who are parking
underneath it and people who are
traveling and going back and forth on uh
store street to keep any kind of debris
that may fall from reaching uh
any of the
people cars
uh anybody transporting back and forth
so that needs been established the
costs are associated with this are 24
million or so for 40 000
per square i mean per space costs that
would include a decent facade for it
approximately three and a half billion
to raise three and a half million to
raise
33 capital about 1.5 or so is estimated
to raise the store street facility
itself and then the balance of that
would be
to look
whether there's escalation cost no
escalation cost whether there'd be a
need to assist doj with the move perhaps
those things would have to be ironed out
and
facilitated one way or another is this
the best process to get get it going
it's the one the speaker and
representative
berger has endorsed it's it gets it on
the table it gets the money's encumbered
it's one way to fund it it's a policy
decision you folks have to make about
funding i'm here to certainly discuss
the need and the critical need for this
critical facility
and continuity of government quite
frankly to keep them going
and and limiting liability in my opinion
uh because that garage is
rapidly becoming a liability to um the
state in my opinion
so with that i'll gladly field any
questions and appreciate the opportunity
to testify a lot of talk without a
representative murray for a question
thank you and thanks for taking my
question i'm just kind of curious uh are
there
new regulations pertaining to new
garages with regards to a certain number
of ev spaces or a percentage of ev
spaces given the size of the garage i'm
not qualified to answer that at this
point that would be an engineering and
design feature i do know that we in the
general court went forward and did
establish a
along with our partners in das over at
the new
boiler plant where the green street
parking is we have four ev
level 2
charges over there
currently and so but it is i believe
it's going to be
future proofing is what i like to call
it when you future proof something you
really look ahead and see what's going
to be established what the needs are
going to be and try to predict those
needs and certainly ev
cars and trucks if you look at all the
major manufacturers that's where they're
headed
thank you
further questions from the committee
representative lynn for what
you know you mentioned that that the um
in terms of where doj is going to go you
mentioned uh one granite place as as one
possibility i guess the the only thing
that would concern me is if if it it
sounded like from what you were saying
that that seemed like it was maybe the
only place that was big enough or
suitable enough and i guess my question
is if it
you know if it's not kind of clear that
that's actually going to work out
um
do we have do we run the risk of having
to you know we
we sort of commit to tearing down the
building across the street and then we
have to build another building for doj
i think
thank you for the question
representative mr chairman i think that
those are some of the things that you
have to discuss is i don't believe that
new building would be required to house
those folks i think you could find them
spaces it's whether you keep them whole
or not if you keep them in one spot
obviously one granite place has a south
and a north building i don't think that
you want to co-mingle the
department of justice with the supreme
court or the aoc or anybody that may
move in there on behalf of the the court
system because they have some separate
uh ideas and
and tasks and missions so i think that
you know there there's space and smaller
square footages probably available but
they would separate them
these days everybody works
electronically so whether that would be
problematic or not i'm not sure but to
find some place consistent
with that kind of square footage in the
city is is pretty much uh negligible
here right now you can't find it you can
go to the mall in the mall up there and
that's probably the only places that
have something around 50 000
plus square feet
so would you have to build a new
building i don't think that that's in
the in the books to do right now for the
house doj but
something
i doubt would happen
thank you
representative mooney for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you mr faf
for your testimony
have any personal injuries or damage to
property been reported over the years
because of store street i'm fully aware
of its condition but i'm curious as to
whether or not any have been reported or
we're just anticipating that as a matter
of time thank you
thank you representative thank you mr
chairman uh quite frankly friday was our
most recent report of an injury it was a
trip injury on the ramp coming from
store street's top deck we've had
several reports of trip and falls over
there
we've had reports of cuts on the rails
from the rust
people using a handrail for its intended
purpose
the handrail is not in the appropriate
condition therefore cut the person's
hand so i've had regular reports of
things along those lines i've had
reports of people
locked into the
stairway towers
because the doors don't function
because of settlement because of
hinges falling off so it's a constant
issue over there its proximity from the
complex
even though we have cameras to be able
to view that we've had vandalism over
there we've had concerns from members
and had them escorted over there when
they worked later at night and you folks
do a lot of your work in the winter so a
lot of times it's dark when you leave
even at four o'clock we've had to escort
folks over there uh because of their
concerns for their own safety we gladly
do that with our protective services
team
so there's a an array of issues from the
proximity of that garage the condition
of that garage and to answer your
questions specifically just as recently
representative hatch for a question yes
thank you mr chair i just want to go
back to the department of justice and
where they're going has there been some
exploration by them or anybody in terms
of placement because this is happening
rather quickly in our terms so
i'm just curious thank you
representative patch mr chairman um yes
in fact we did have a discussion uh
we've had some meetings
as recently as last wednesday the
attorney general and his chief of staff
and um commissioner arlinghaus and and
um his assistants have uh and members of
his team have met with uh
with us here for the general court in
the webster room as a matter of fact and
we've had an on-site visit to
the potential site uh to see and do a
walk-through and a condition assessment
of it
so we've done some exploratory
efforts
because the gate quite frankly is that
they're still occupying the site where
is the best potential to place the new
garage well i didn't question your dude
no further saying no further questions
from the committee
thank you chief
thank you very much mr chairman members
we'll next call on commissioner
arlinghaus
from department of administrative
services
which could be accompanied by karen
say the last name
that's a good guess
uh
well you know who i am you just
introduce me um so i'm the commissioner
vet administrative services and and
karen is here because she's the director
of plant and
um she's an engineer whereas i've never
even tried to drive a train
and um
uh to talk about excuse me can i have
your last name again please i wouldn't i
wasn't writing fast enough karen
rantamacki director of plant and
and we are only going to talk about
section 8 and nothing else
um
before we start i want to say the sore
street garage is not semi-safe it's safe
and i think that's an important thing to
say we would not operate a garage that
was semi-safe that's i know what you
were saying i'm just i don't want anyone
to think that they're in imminent danger
that there are any problems it's
perfectly fine
um and
that's that's like that's an important
thing otherwise we would put a gate at
the end of the ramp and you wouldn't be
allowed into it um
so there are a couple things uh and i'm
not here to vouch for the 35 million
dollars that that estimate was developed
without our assistance and and i i can
look into that
um and if you wanted to talk about
engineering at some point we could have
public works talk to you about the
process um we did do as as terry
mentioned
um we had meetings in 2019 there was a
and at that time there was a thought
about following the traditional legal
department of public works process for
for building a building a garage and
there were meetings with uh
design selection we actually picked a
design firm
consisted of an architect and then also
a garage firm for lack of a better word
and then we canceled them a week later
because um
there was a there were questions about
other options downtown
and i don't know all the details but
there was a thought about
doj somewhere else and and building a
garage so what i would love to do is if
you go forward with this process and i
understand that your intent is to not
follow the traditional public works
process and just have the legislature do
it on its own
which is fine but
i would it would be great if you gave
some credence to that process just
because we invited
uh five or six different companies to
come in and spend enormous amounts of
time and money to make a presentation to
us and i
and in the back of my head i can't help
thinking we did that we should at least
do that
if you want to build a parking garage
and that's your choice
you have to
tear down that building
if you want to tear down that building
you have to get rid of the people in it
or do it on a weekend
um and uh
and they have to have somewhere to go
the moving costs to move the department
of justice would be roughly and this is
a ballpark estimate 1.25 million and
that's derived based on uh an
extrapolation from the cost of moving
oplc
and everyone else who was in philbrook
last year but it's a good ballpark
number 1.25 million
it is true that there is almost no space
in concord that would suit 50 000 square
feet the only one is the old lincoln
financial building
known as one granite place
we did both tour that facility um
two weeks ago
ish somewhere like that it's about a
hundred thousand square feet there's a
lot of space you'd have room for other
people to go into it
my understanding is the purchase price
would likely be in the neighborhood of
20 million dollars to buy that building
i don't know what the rental the leasing
cost would be but the buying cost is
about 20 million dollars
if you don't do that i don't know
exactly where else they go but you'd
have to break them up and move them
about
and we don't have extra the state
manages about 2 million
square feet of space in concord in terms
of office space not counting
corrections and hospitals and stuff
and we don't have extra
there's some buildings falling down
that probably should fall down that
you could try to convert but that's kind
of where things are that's sort of the
big picture on that on that part of it
um
and and i don't and i i can't testify
without talking to public works in
greater depths about how many years of
life the
mr ramtamaki anything
nothing to add thank you
must have been very complete thank you
next call up on
representative graham chairman of public
works
not often i'm at this end of this
committee room
um
thank you mr chairman for the record i
am representative john graham
hillsborough district 7 and as the
chairman said i'm
the chairman of public works um
i actually came up here because i was
more concerned about the amendment that
we're not discussing and how that was
going to work
i'm going to talk about both mr chairman
if you'll let me
um
that
and then we'll call him back all right
now i'm not staying talk about this
another commitment that i have to be at
all right
go ahead
okay
okay i'll talk about the garage over the
last couple of um
terms we've sunk some money into sorcery
to keep it so that it is usable and
that's all been bonded money i want to
reiterate what the speaker said about
let's do it with cash if we bond 30 40
million dollars to do this it will
impact our next capital budget
we do about 130 million dollars a year
uh term
in capital budget expenditures if we
take a quarter of it for a parking
garage there will be needs within the
state that are not met so if we have the
cash let's use cash let's not let
anybody in this body or the other talk
about bonding it if we can i would
that's about all we do need to do it and
i nobody i don't think is going to say
we want to try to fix stores
it's just not gonna work um
if we are talking about um
additional monies for
another building we'll have to talk
about that whether that should be
included in this or we talk about it
next term to buy another building for
doj
but that's another big chunk of money if
we're talking as we just said 20 million
dollars
and i would ask that at some point
we asked public works um charlie uh
commission charlie allen has his people
to actually look at the cost to make
sure that 35 million dollars is going to
cover
with escalating costs we just don't know
so we should do that but we need to move
forward with this and get it to the
senate and that can be done in the
senate since we only have a week and a
half left of of our work
on the rebate um as i said i came up to
talk about the other i just want to make
sure that when we're talking about the
rebate that
it means that
um whoever has paid the registration
going forward too has paid it and that
the 12 that goes to cities and towns is
being taken out and giving it before
they get the 25
back
because that's important for all of us
because that maintains our local roads
which was
part of my concern with with the other
suggestion but this works and having
talked with safety i know it would cost
a whole lot more to do rebates than to
do
the registration rebate well that's all
i wanted to say
mr chairman um didn't mean to be abrupt
thank you
thank you for your input any questions
from the committee members
seeing none
i'm going to assume that many of the
other cards are
talking about the parking garage i want
to go through those testimonies before i
get to the rebate on the
registration
i
see i was going to next call on steve
lavoy from the department of
transportation
but he's going to talk about the dmv so
uh anybody else
i'll come to you stephen let me see if
i've got everybody that wants to talk
about the parking crash
uh
speaker jasper wants to say something
like commissioner jasper wants to say
welcome
thank you mr
chairman and
i members of the committee i'm really
here as a former speaker maybe a little
bit into my role as as commissioner and
how the parking relates to the
department
i'm not going to reiterate what you've
heard from the previous speakers
i think you all know that the parking
garage is
beyond its life
span
i'm really pleased to hear that that
double netting was put there only for
aesthetics and had nothing to do with
safety
um
so that's that's comforting
um that parking garage when i got here
to the legislature i was elected in
1984 so the parking garage was only
about nine years old it's interesting to
note when we talk about average age that
after all those years i'm still younger
than the average member of the
legislature i got a few more years to go
to catch up to the average
but this is not a project that
was just thought up
recently
when i was speaker this was something
that
my then chief of staff
terry poff and i were very concerned
about at that time and i've been out of
the speaker's chair for uh four and a
half years at the at this point and
we've been talking about it for for
longer than that and that was the site
we were considering at at the time
you know
i believe that everybody understands we
need to have a new parking garage
everybody has for probably decades the
problem is we keep getting into these
details of will where's doj going to go
you know where doj
started out
many years ago
the speaker's office
speaker roberts
told me that when he was the majority
leader for uh
a former speaker whose name escaped
marshall cobley marshall sent him in to
say to warren rudman who was the
attorney general at the time do you want
to move now or after christmas or before
or after christmas
moved over actually interestingly into
the office that i now occupy
in the annex so moving the doj around is
uh
is something that has happened several
times and and that can't be our primary
concern
you know not only from the safety
concerns that you've heard about
from the fact that we have a volunteer
legislature
what we've been asking them to do for
all these years by walking
um you know what a block and a half
is disgraceful
you know this is something that should
be done anyhow when i was a young clerk
of the judiciary committee i had a
parking space right out in front of the
annex
and over the years we've had more and
more people elected the legislature who
have walking disabilities and now the
clerks
can't have those those spaces and in
fact
the city's been very gracious over the
years and i want to thank the mayor for
his cooperation during my time as
speaker and um even now as commissioner
we've had to to turn to him a few times
for for some help but the city shouldn't
have to constantly give up that revenue
because we don't want to do what we know
we need to do we let the details
drive this discussion and so we move
decade after decade
some someday that garage is going to
be unusable
and then what are we going to do with
our members let's worry more about what
we're going to do with 400 members
if the parking garage becomes unusable
then all right what are we going to do
with the doj we can solve that problem
we can solve that quickly we won't be
able to solve the parking problem
quickly at all so i would encourage you
even though we know this is not a
perfect plan that it's come in late
we have time to fix it going to have
time
even in the next session if this isn't
perfect to make adjustments to a plan
but now we have the cash you've heard
that look we're going to affect other
capital projects if we bond it
we don't need to do that now we just
need to bite the bullet we need to do
what has needed to be done for well over
in my estimation you know 30 years at
this time and have a permanent solution
so that all the members of the
legislature
are treated equally and with the respect
they deserve not have second class
legislators and in fact that is what we
have
by the way we have dealt with this i'll
be glad to answer any questions
but and thank you for your time
okay as anyone else want to comment on
thank you very much mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is dan mcguire i'm from epsom
and i'm here today on behalf of granite
state taxpayers the state's
oldest statewide taxpayer organization
so we're opposed to this parking garage
on on a couple of different grounds
one is process i know you heard from the
chair of public works who thinks this is
just fine
but in fact this is a capital project
and this the
legislature has a very good procedure
for capital projects which is they do a
bi-annual budget and all of the
different projects get considered by the
public works committee
who look at those things year after year
and have a lot of experience in
judging one project compared to another
this is
a building that would be around for who
knows how long 40 years or more and
it's a capital project and it should be
part of that process rather than as a
legislative special thrown in here
for a very quick vote
financially
i do think this is a time to
consider borrowing
we're in a time of low interest rates
and high inflation so borrowing is
something to think about even pushing
the the limits of the normal capital
budget
uh next time
um then there's the overall cost of the
project you're adding a considerable
amount i mean i understand that that
that location would be great for the
comfort of the legislature there's no
question about it
but
that location adds a huge amount of cost
to the whole project the the three point
something million to tear the building
down the one point something million to
move the department of justice
the extra three four five million to
make it look commensurate with the
neighborhood the aesthetics of the thing
and so on
um i don't know if they've considered an
alternative of simply replacing the
parking garage at its existing location
right that that wouldn't have to be
fancy could be built as a as an
inexpensive as possible parking garage
that's not a location that needs any
special architecture or whatever so
so that's something to consider then you
wouldn't pay you would keep this
building you wouldn't have to move
anybody all those kind of things that
would certainly save i don't know if it
would save half the cost but it might
save a third or something i mean it
would it would be a lot of money
um and then the other thing to think
about is more the
the sort of long-term aspect of this
there are technological changes in
progress
that would make a parking garage in
particular kind of a white elephant long
term
so i'm thinking of two things one is
self-driving cars
you know it's not something that's going
to happen next year or the year after
but 10 years 20 years 30 years from now
you're going to drive to a place get out
and your car will go park itself
somewhere
right it doesn't need a garage nearby
so
your estimate of when that's going to
happen would have bearing on
how long term you know do you really
want
the primo
[Music]
beautiful garage that's permanent here
or is it something to think about what's
the temporary solution what's the short
term intermediate term solution
similarly there's also
um
virtual reality
right that's something that's not there
yet but it's getting better and better
all the time and if it was to the stage
where you could interact with other
people as though you're sitting in the
same room with them
i'm sure that there's plenty of
representatives hopefully is maybe such
as our the chairman here who doesn't
want to drive two hours a day each
direction
to get here and do the work you know so
so both of those things long term
speak to parking garages is not a good
business to get into i guess is the best
way i can put that so thank you mr
chairman
all right now
now i will okay
do you want to talk about the garage
okay
all right
yeah i apologize if i jumped in too soon
so i'm
i'm representing timothy horrigan that
represents stratfor county district six
the towns of durham and madbury and
the new garage is long overdue and i
know it's
goes against our grain here in the
legislature to spend money especially to
spend money on ourselves and also to
spend money before we absolutely need to
but i think this project needs to be
built and it um needs to uh
i think uh
you know
the honorable terry faff who's a former
former state legislator he said it right
that's like we're about three years from
uh the building collapsing that's about
how long it'll take us to do it if we uh
do it right so i um
i think 35 million is probably not an
unrealistically high figure i think we
should uh go the extra shovel to build a
uh
build a good building one that looks
good and it's structurally sound not
building on the cheap like we apparently
did um well it's almost 50 years ago
that we built a building dates back to
1975 when my uh
father was a member and um
um in terms of uh we should probably
talk about future proofing it we should
probably be making it uh expandable i
know
we all have a wish list of things we
might want to add to that site and i
certainly do i certainly um
i would certainly say one particular
priority is uh the
expanding the system of tunnels from uh
from the state house the tunnel collect
the llb the state house
it's prone to flooding and it's also
like extremely um inconsistent with
the you know dis americans for
disability act requirements so that
we could probably add a tunnel from the
new parking garage to the state house
annex across the state house for a
relatively uh small cost and that um i
think also some versions of plan even
consider putting
offices a retail space in there which is
uh worth worth considering and
i've even thought a good idea would be
to
keep the reps hall just as a the
historic reps haul and build ourselves a
slightly larger facility to meet and i
think we found out the last couple of
years
even though it cost a lot of money was
inconvenient to meet offsite uh there
was more space and that
was helpful in a variety of ways in
terms of uh
doing our work on session days
res mcguire brought up a virtual reality
i think it's a long time before uh we'll
be ready to do that um even though i've
worked in virtual reality and certainly
we already have um
the zoom technology which we
could theoretically have used i may
democrat our party has a lawsuit saying
we should have used it but um you know
we made a decision that wasn't suitable
for our needs and that's uh
it's going to be a few years before
we're ready to make a different decision
on that one and that still doesn't
update the need for uh
for us to gather you know gather in
person i don't think it ever replaced
that and um so
so i think i think we should go ahead
and start building building the garage i
drove when i drove here today i drove
behind the new uh
grand stand for the football stadium and
that cost 25 million dollars plus a few
million dollars for other ancillary
processes and um you know they
that's a fairly simple facility but it
looks good it should last them a long
time and i think um
the same same issue for the parking
garage which i think is a project of
about the same same scope so i hope you
uh hope we begin quickly i hope we make
something that's uh
you know easily future proofable and
mutually easy easily expandable and um
even though it's a little bit
inconsistent with how they usually do
capital budgeting here in the state
which in turn is inconsistent with how
they do in the private sector i'm
if the uh
if the money if the money if the money
if the cash is there we may as well uh
you know set it aside now and get
started uh started now rather than
waiting you know a couple of years to do
what's already going to be a very long
project and um
another wasn't recognized for the uh
part about the rebate certainly that's a
lot simpler than
that thing with
collecting receipts for the gas tax that
would probably have taken more than 92
people to do so that was like just a
very complicated scheme and this lease
is simple whether it make much
difference to anyone you know
i'll probably take the 25 and uh you
know spend it on a uh spend it on a
burger and a beer at hopping grind in
durham and i suppose if they had also
had a
room to meals tax holiday that would
reduce the cost of my meal by another
couple of bucks but anyway so
let's anyway i agree we should um it's a
good plan let's make a good plan for the
parking garage and we may as well start
sooner rather than later and uh yeah i
think we should probably do it
do a good job rather than a bad job and
um hopefully
oh yes and also i'm on the judiciary
committee so i've toured both the one
granite place that's a very beautiful
facility that certainly would be a good
fine home for department justice or any
other uh
or any other state agency and also
the bank building as ever said i mean it
at least it looks nice from the outside
but it's
cramped the roof leaks it's uh
you know they do great work in there but
it's not a good you know it's not a
suitable situation for them so like you
know that's uh both
although maybe it keeps them humble just
like that uh terrible looking parking
garage keeps me a little bit humble you
know i drive in every morning and i sort
of know i'm really not that big a deal
if i have to park my car in that place
that looks like something out of a
dystopia but
so let's build a new parking garage
thanks
i can answer any questions if you still
have any
any questions from the committee members
saying none thank you representative
thank you
well next call on
deputy commissioner steve lavoie from
are you
in a rush to go anywhere representative
lads yeah i'm trying to get up to my
good afternoon steve lavoy director of
administration for the department of
safety and with me is scott breyer the
chief of our road toll bureau
first i'd like to start by thanking
representative umberger for um listening
to the concerns that the department had
related to the first uh draft of the
amendment um and and for putting this
amendment forward um
we we we believe this is really a policy
decision for the legislature and so
we're not taking a position
for or against this
but i'm here today to really talk about
the administrative component of this of
this mechanism so as written
there would be a rebate provided of 25
to any individual or business for each
of their
motor vehicle registrations as written
this includes
all registrations so that would be
trailers
motor vehicles commercial motor vehicles
motorcycles
there are about 1.6 million
registrations
as in during february that number could
change by the time the bill
becomes effective
so we're looking at about 40 million
dollars 40.1 million dollars in total as
it stands today
assuming that the language in paragraph
is really referring to general funds
that addresses our big concern about the
impact of the highway fund so if general
funds are used for this rebate
you know we can maintain this this
neutral position
if the highway fund were going to be
impacted that would be a concern
for for us and for
any of the other departments who utilize
the highway fund because it's not the
healthiest of funds from a revenue
perspective
there would need to be some coordination
between the dmv and the department of
administrative services and also the
state treasury
there'd be over a million
1.6
there'll probably be about a million
over a million checks that would need to
be processed in order for this to happen
not sure of a time frame as of yet we
would need to coordinate with those
other agencies to make sure we didn't
overwhelm our existing processing
systems
but there are a few pieces too that that
i'd offer for consideration to make this
more effective from an amendment
perspective one is there should be some
sort of consideration related to those
administrative costs to produce those
checks in such a large quantity postage
alone is going to be over eight hundred
thousand dollars
there would also be some special check
stock that that i believe is utilized
and there may even be special ink
toner printing related to the check
stock that's used i don't know what
those costs are those are something that
administrative services would have to um
help provide and weigh in on but that is
a consideration related to this bill
the other piece that uh
is is has to do with the use of the of
the term rebate so currently
registrations uh they vary in in amount
some registrations um can be
significantly expensive and are above 25
others for example a motorcycle a
motorcycle registration is 15
so
using the term rebate
and then having a set amount equal to 25
brings up a few questions about whether
or not a motorcycle would receive the
full 25 amount or would they receive a
15 amount um there'd be a couple of
options to address that we could
look for maybe different language for
rebates to say it's a flat 25 fee
or if the rebate stays we'd have to
determine how do we how do we deal with
that moving into the future registration
periods is that a credit on a customer's
account if it exceeds the 15 but that
that can all be worked out um through
work sessions and in other discussions
but those those are the two areas that i
think um
uh would be able to to make this easier
to administer um and ensure that we
could do so based on the intent of the
bill
and i'm happy to address any questions
that anybody might have
just the concern about the highway fund
i would say for the administrative
pieces it's just reinforced that should
thank you
questions from the committee
representative griffin
yes commissioner i wonder um a are
trailers going to be included and what's
uh thank you for the question so as
written uh the trailers would be
included
they could be excluded with a change in
the language of the bill
one could argue that a a trailer
exerts a toll on the vehicle that's
pulling it and so you would lose gas
mileage and therefore consume more gas
and
receive some sort of a benefit related
to that a relief related to that
representative turcotte for a question
thank you mr chair thank you mr levoy
for
coming today uh quick question on
i know you mentioned 800 000 for postage
or because with checks
uh could you do you have a rough
estimate on the number of man hours that
would be involved in
taking care of this
um i don't at this point um
we we're we're confident that we could
absorb those costs with existing
staffing
but that would be the piece that we need
to coordinate with the other state
agencies
and and really true up what type of a
schedule we'd be looking at
this is not something i think that we
could generate overnight and the state i
don't think would be in a position to
produce a million checks tomorrow um so
my thought would be with looking at over
a several month period uh of coordinated
processing on a day-to-day basis to work
through that that
volume
questions
you could do it with existing staffs
without the necessity of going to
overtime or anything like that
uh there would likely need to be some
overtime associated uh with this um how
much is is unknown at this point would
it all depend upon
maintaining daily workloads while while
processing these types of this type of
data
so you know further questions thank you
gentlemen
now we'll call on representative land
thank you very much mr chair and members
of the committee
for the record my name is rick ladd i am
chair of house education and they also
come from haverhill new hampshire
we have lots of land up there for
parking
um
you yeah well we have rail up there too
so
um i'd like to address this this
amendment in terms of 1661.
from the policy perspective
house education working with the
advisory council on career technical
education working on subcommittee
working with directors working with
business
have been working for the last seven to
eight years and you see the culmination
of that effort would 1661.
we don't want to see this bill
jeopardized
next when i look at this amendment and
getting on to the amendment i know that
representative want me to talk directly
to the amendment
that
there's two parts basically section six
and seven
and part eight and then with the
effective dates nine
i'm reticent and i would be reticent on
the house floor to even think of voting
for section six and seven
vehicle registration rebate checks don't
rise to the level of an emergency
extenuating circumstance or a safety
issue that the latter part of this
amendment does
now we've had 103 bills this year in
house education
i've had my clerk who's new
walking back to stores in the middle of
the dark which we're concerned for her
safety
and we know that there's issues within
the building but just walking from here
to there that's tough for
young people to do alone
there's a need to do something with
stores i agree that is
a significant emergency extenuating
circumstance
and safety issue
which needs address
and i i can support that
i don't think if we got the bill on the
floor and had this amendment
alone in other words divide this thing
out with a new amendment there's a
stronger possibility of seeing it going
forward my chief concern is that
we have a number of students throughout
this state that need
1661.
we have a number of businesses talk to
the bia talk to the chamber talk to the
new hampshire bankers association
they're all saying help us get more
skilled employee
people prepared for the career pathways
in this state
we have a demographic problem we can't
see this one go down the toilet
so if we're going to amend it for
something do it right
look at the issue in this latter part of
this amendment stores i know there's a
process
yes but we have an emergency we have
extenuating what we haven't done to this
point that's under the bridge we need to
go forward make sure things are safe so
in conclusion i'd like to emphasize tear
this amendment apart get rid of part of
it and move forward with the part that
we really really need thank you
thank you for your input any questions
from the committee members
saying
none representative heath thank you mr
chair
thank you for your testimony today i we
don't often agree
but on this i agree i i am really
troubled
um by the amount of work the garage i
completely understand it is an emergency
and we do need to act on it but the
other element of this amendment
there are other things that i think rise
to a level of much greater need in our
state i think about the department of ed
there are no curriculum people there i
think of health and human services i
think of so many other ways that we
could spend the money that we thankfully
have available to us right now so
what is your feeling in terms of a
better use for this money
there are there are a lot of better uses
just looking the title of the bill 1661
career tech education we're at the end
of a round of capital improvements out
there we've gone through the 23
buildings
now it's time our how are we going to
start going back through this process we
need to look at that process but to
ensure that we have proper equipment and
technology in these cte centers we're
talking capital money so that's just one
that i can just right off the bat tell
any further from the committee members
seeing none thank you thank you chairman
have a good ride home
all right before i get to the cte uh
testimony i have one more person here
from d.o.t
thank you for coming
thank you representative weiler
kathy mulcahy hampson i
my privilege to appear before the
committee this afternoon on behalf of
the department of transportation as the
legislative liaison and the senior
madam chair members of the committee um
the department has
appreciated your support especially the
support from madam chair and members of
division two for the past several
sessions and i know you're familiar with
the state of the highway fund
i have less to say this afternoon when
the amendment changed from a road toll
rebate to
a registration fee rebate
issue i'd like to raise one issue the
department has with the
language of the amendment and i
recognize that the amendment was very
recently pulled together and i think it
perhaps is a point that was overlooked
but as drafted it could impact the
highway fund though though not intended
and steve lavoy and scott briar from the
department of safety
touched on this
but i don't want to miss an opportunity
to protect the highway fund amendment
number 1162 specifically appropriates
the general funds for the the rebate
checks but there's no mention of how to
pay the costs that department of safety
would incur with the rebate check
process
and the time and resources that they
spend translates to money and that money
would come from the highway fund unless
it's specifically
stated otherwise in the amendment
i don't know how much it costs for this
state to
issue a check i think it's a little
cumbersome
it does cost money and there would be a
million checks or more issued
so we don't want that to impact the
highway fund i don't know if it would be
less expensive to
issue
charge 25 dollars less at the time of
registration
and i don't know what the cost involved
with that would be but it's something
that perhaps the committee could look at
but i asked that and further discussions
on this amendment that the costs not be
incurred
processing the rebate checks
against the highway fund
and i thank you
thank you for your testimony any
questions from the members of the
committee representative mooney thank
you mr chairman thank you for your
testimony it's interesting you mentioned
that about almost a discount a discount
is forward-looking
a rebate is retro i'm hearing the
department of safety talking about all
these checks manpower over time to
process the like
any
opinions either from the department of
safety if i could be so bold from the
previous speaker or yourself in terms of
that
alternative
of a forward-looking discount for the
next year when you register your vehicle
as opposed to the retro rebate for
everyone thank you
thank you for the question
representative mooney i'd have to defer
to the department of safety dmv is under
that department and they're familiar
with the
systems and the costs involved in
any other committee member want question
seeing none thank you ma'am thank you mr
weiler
okay now i have
the remaining pink cards from people
with the career technical education
we'll call first on chris dodge from the
salem
uh
education and and
honorable mcguire wants to speak as well
about that
about the rebate
okay i'll come to you afterwards
all right mr dodge welcome to finance
committee thank you mr chair and thank
you committee members uh for hearing my
testimony today i'll be brief
um as someone who worked a lot of hours
working with the cte tuition and
transportation committee
on the original bill in the original
text of the bill and someone who's been
in the trenches with cte for 15 years
now
really trying to advance some of these
challenges particularly with
calendar alignment and embedded credit
without getting into the the build text
i was
really surprised that we took a really
nice clean bill and now
we've really muddied the waters and it
it's it's gone from being the cte bill
to being the parking garage bill or the
rebate bill so i'm just i have concerns
in that regard i don't doubt that that
facility based on what i'm hearing today
is in dire need of replacement and i'm
not opposition to that but my concern is
that we've taken a bill that sailed
through house education
and was expected to sail through this
committee with minimal
financial burden and now we've attached
a significant amount of money to it so
my concern is that what is the fate of
this bill going to be now
based on this amendment
and i'm happy to answer any questions
mr dodge if i could uh
away some of your fears from my
experience when we put in
these non-uh germain amendments it's
generally on a very safe bill that we
don't think anybody wants to kill
so that's one of the reasons why it gets
amended to a bill that's
on its way safely
we add things to it and they can always
be amended out
thank you
in my opinion there's no need to be
fearful of cte
and what you've worked on so hard and i
appreciate the time you spent on that
because thank you i agree with you we
need to encourage it more and just just
bearing in mind that some of the some of
the language in this bill is is
a game changer for us as part of that so
thank you we'll make sure it moves
thank you
any questions from the committee seeing
none we'll next call on
steve rothberg for the uh
also a cte supporter
good afternoon my name is steve
rothenberg i'm the principal at the
korean technical center here in concord
i don't need to hash over what was said
already
this bill
has some themes in it that are
positioned korean technical education
not for today but for a number of years
uh the concept of embedded credits
is very very important it changes the
way students think about high school
whether they earn english credits and
math credits in an area they're going to
focus on
and i'll remind the committee and
represent wildlife i appreciate what you
said a minute ago so there are 14 000
give or take graduates every year in new
hampshire
which is obviously seniors mostly
of those
there's 9 500 korean technical kids in
the state of new hampshire so um out of
28 000 students who are juniors and
seniors plus or minus 9 500 are
occurring technical education
so we start talking about money and
investments uh investing in those 9 500
students which represents a significant
portion of new hampshire high school
students is huge and uh this little bill
and i appreciate what you said earlier
representative weiler and i know
representative berger is very passionate
about it too and there are other folks
here who have been very involved how
important it is to
build a new building give the rebates
it's not my comment in fact building a
building be great because our
construction students love places to
work um but in a larger sense it's just
so important that uh these this bill
continues on and is seen as as a
separate entity whatever whatever
thank you mr rothenberg
principal rothenberg any questions
seeing none
well mcguire did you want to add
anything
yes thank you mr chairman um
so first of all just briefly to
speak to representative lad's point i
think that
it's likely
this is not likely to cause a problem in
the house in the sense that if off to
pass with amendment doesn't doesn't go
through i would think that the speaker
would allow you to divide the question
and vote separately
on sections one through five and the
other sections and so on um it does it's
it still is a possible problem when it
gets to the governor because he can
either only veto the whole thing or not
but but as far as the house goes i don't
think it's a serious problem
and obviously the senate is used to
dealing with bills of multiple issues so
it might be worth
giving them a little of their own back
but um
anyways
but i wanted to speak i came here today
prepared to speak against the original
[Music]
reduction for the exact same reason that
the department of safety objected to it
because it's easy to see that the
highway fund is going to be in trouble
in the next budget cycle
right the cost of gas is way up that
means the cost of asphalt is up
the cost of diesel is up and so on and
also people will be driving less so the
gas tax revenues will be down you don't
have to be nor major to figure that out
right
so so anything that hurts the highway
fund is something you want to stay off
of uh this year but if it's strictly
general funds then it's certainly up to
you how you spend them and whatever i
mean there's plenty of other places to
to do things with the general funds but
uh including leaving them for the next
budget so but that's up to you thank you
thank you for your comments any uh
questions from the committee members
seeing none
anybody else wishes to add anything to
any portion of house bill 1661
seeing none
i will close the hearing at
3 30 on
1661. thank you all
okay uh division two we'll see you uh
down there i'll be there in about five
minutes
67.
you